After my parents split up. Uh... I was living in uh... my mother's house in our
old house on Yarmouth road in Philadelphia with my mother and my little brother
and one Christmas morning. I came down the stairs and underneath the tree.
There were all these really large-scale gifts and they were all addressed to me.
And I ripped them open. And it was luggage. In, um, all
different shapes
and sizes.
And with this beautiful floral print, and I said, 'Oh my God, mom, there's so many of
them.' And she said, 'Well you know when you're going on a big trip it's nice to have a matching set.'
And I said 'Who's going on the big trip?' And she said 'You are. And
your little brother, you know your father gives me no help here, I'm sending you both out to California to live with him.'
So now
I'm in California and I've been living with my father for like ten years and, uh, and at this
point I'm fifteen and my little brother's eleven. And my
father's sixty eight years old, he's not a young man but you know he's doing OK and we're going along and it all
seems, you know fine. Until one day, my father's girlfriend
offers him this deal,
And her name is Retta Herschfield. And she, she's a widow. A
two-time widow, and she she's my father's age and she's put a little money aside, not a lot,
but enough. When she says to my father, 'Look
Manny, you can either go into old age in style, you can move into
my condominium complex with, with, with all the amenities and all that that affords,
my swimming pool,
the... the laundry room and the free parking,
Me and my Hamilton collection of a limited edition Gone With the Wind plates.
Or you could continue living with those two kids of yours in that crappy rental apartment on
La Cienega Boulevard that you can barely afford.' So that's sort of what it came down to, either the condominium or the kids and my
father went with the condo.
So now it's like eighteen
years later, and I'm living in the East Village, and I'm like thirty three years old
and I'm, uh, and I haven't seen my father very much during the course of this time. So
one day the phone rings and the answering machine picks up, and it's
my father's girlfriend's daughter, Retta Herschfield's daughter, she lives in Hawaii and
she
says 'Aloha.
I just thought you should know that my mother, Retta Herschfield, has had a stroke and
we had to hire a twenty-four hour home health care worker to attend to her
needs and, uh, Tammy, the fact of the matter is your father's not getting any younger
either and actually, uh, Tammy, the fact is he won't dress
himself and he's wandering around the apartment in the nude. And he's showing up at the dinner
table nude, and he's like a nudist, and
we're really concerned and we are paying Alonzo to take care of our mother, not your father, and
we you know we don't think it's fair, and I don't know what kind of people you are you don't even talk to your father, you're a bunch of
savages.' And then she said 'You know, oh and I also want you to know that your father's in the hospital. I mean it's nothing
serious it's apparently routine, but I just thought you should know.
Aloha.' So
my brother, my big brother and I, we fly out to California to meet
with Alonzo and to check out the situation, the home health care worker, and
we strike up a deal with him that we're going to give him you know, we're going to kind of pool our money and we're going to give him this
monthly payment if he continues to care for our father and he agrees to this and that's all very nice and we sign
a little piece of paper and that's all really great, and then we go to the hospital to see my
father. And you know I haven't seen my father in a really long time and we get to the
hospital and
he's in a hospital bed, and now he's quite old, he's like eighty six years old and he's laying there and it's all
very sort of sarcophagus-strange feeling in the room,
And I'm... and it's silent, and then suddenly my father's eyes sort of pop open.
And he looks at me. And I look at him, and he says, you know, 'Where the hell have you been? They've had
me hog tied for days, get me the hell outta here.' And he starts pulling at these
restraints. And I start to undo him, and I try to explain to him that I've been living on the eastern
seaboard for the last eighteen years, and, you know I'm sorry I'm
late dad. So I untie
my father, and apparently he's going to be released in a few days and everything's set
with Alonzo. So my brother flies back to Boston Massachusetts where he lives.
And now everything starts happening very quickly. I'm still in Los Angeles
and I'm actually in my hotel room and I'm preparing to leave as well. And then the phone
rings. 'Aloha. Tammy. I just want you to know that
last night our mother Retta Herschfield passed away. And we just. I
mean we feel really terrible about this I mean we're really sad we're really sorry and we're selling the
condo. And I just want to wish, you know you and your family good luck
and God health and Aloha.' So now.
My father, this deal that we made with the home health care worker is moot
because my father has no home.
And the hospital is ready to release my father but he has nowhere to go and I immediately call my big brother.
And he immediately starts scrambling to find some sort of facility that will take care of my father
and will receive him in a very short period of time. And I'm in Los Angeles and I'm really kind of freaking
out I'm stalling the hospital they're getting really mad at me because you know it's a hospital and they're explaining it's not a nursing
home and I can't drive and I'm in L.A. My brother calls me and he finds a
place. And that's going to take my father, and this is a big relief so I call up
the airlines. I call United. And I'm looking for what's called
a compassion discount fair. And, uh,
the woman on the phone, the United woman on the phone, she was very nice. But she explained to
me that United doesn't offer
compassion. They only offer bereavement.
So if your father's still alive, I'm sorry but we can't help you, but when your
father does die,
please feel free to call United and then we'll be able to take care of him then.
OK so I end up, we're flying American, and it's the morning of the flight and I show up at the hospital, and
It's quite early in the morning, and the hospital's sort of empty and I arrive at my
father's room. He's all... the bed's all made, and my father's all dressed up.
But the odd thing is the way my father's dressed. He's wearing sort of a flannel shirt and he's
wearing these suspenders. And this kind of baseball
cap. This does not suit my father this does not illustrate my
father's personality all. I mean it has nothing to do with my father. He was a nightclub owner and then he was a car salesman and,
and he does, this is like generic grandpa wear, and also my father is a
Jew and they don't wear those sorts of things. Suspenders
and flannel shirts and it was very strange and I was very uncomfortable with it because I thought that my father was sort
of losing a sense of
identity. You know, through this aging process, and people were buying him clothes and they didn't know who he was so
I pulled off the cap and I pulled off the suspenders and I wheel my father out to the nursing station and
I'm signing him out, you know then they're giving me like, medication and dosage instructions, and
they're very kind and then they start stuffing my carry-on luggage with diapers.
These adult diapers which I was completely unprepared for but I didn't have time to ask any questions and we, you
know, we had a plane to catch. So I'm rolling my father out of the hospital. And then I'm
like, 'Dad. By the way, do you know where we're
going?' And he says. 'Yeah. We're going back East.' And he sort
of laughs diabolically like I'm springing him from the penitentiary or something.
So OK, so we get to the airport and you know we're doing pretty well, and we arrive at the
security check out point. And I'm putting all of our, you know, carry
on luggage on that conveyor belt to be X-rayed,
and somehow in the course of negotiating all of this I've misplaced my
father. And then I look beyond the security point, my father's
already gone through. And he's out there in a wheelchair and it's kind of it's like
he's rolling it.
And they're checking me to see what I've got on me, and I'm trying to explain to them my father is
rolling away.
And they don't care, and then there's nothing I can do and at that moment I just I
realize actually you know, that, um, he is kind of helpless, and there is nothing that
I can
do. And, but I'm going to do the best I can. And so
I catch up with him and I get to the gate. And we arrive at the gate. And they're boarding the plane.
And then there's that moment where you realize, like OK. A wheelchair is like, this wide.
And like, an airplane aisle is like, this wide. So how do people in
wheelchairs get aboard
airplanes? And I'll tell you, they have the thing, it's quite, it's this thing and they pull it out of nowhere, it's sort of like
a wheelchair and like a gurney and like a
skateboard. And it's very low and narrow and they take my father off of the wheelchair and they put him
on to this skateboard gurney
thing. And they strap him on, they tilt him back, and they roll him into coach. So there
we are, now we're, we're sitting in coach and my father's got the window seat which is lovely and
I've got, you know I'm sitting there, and anyway the thing is that we're on the plane and that we made it and that we
actually we look like people on a
plane. And you know we're like passing. and
We peel back
the entrees and we're eating our fettucini
or Alfredo or whatever, and it's quite nice. And suddenly,
my father's fork goes down.
And then he starts tugging at his seat belt, and I say, you know, 'Dad - What?' And he says:
'Bathroom.' And so we're at the
point in the plane ride where the tray tables are down and that little service cart thing is in the
aisle
and everybody's eating and taking up space. My father has to go to the bathroom and I... OK. So I managed to sort
of wiggle him out from behind those little flappy tray tables. I get him out into the aisle.
And I... and he's very... you know, unstable and I'm not really sure how we're going to get from where we are to back there
where the bathroom is.
And then I think you know I'll be like one of those aluminum walkers that you see the elderly with and I
will become a human walker. And I face my father towards me and I hold him in
his hands like this and I just want to do this with as much, you know, like a private
dignified moment as much as I can.
And we're sort of, you know we're walking backwards towards the bathroom and it's going pretty well
actually, I mean it's a little shaky and it's this kind of odd little thing but nobody really seems to suspect
anything. And you know it seems to be OK and then suddenly my father sort of sticks in place
and he stops walking. And I look down to discover that his pants are around
his ankles. And that he's standing in the middle of this airplane in his
diapers. And then I realized oh my god the suspenders were actually necessary.
They just offended my sensibility and I mean we felt
really [bleeped] and awful and responsible for humiliating my father, and I pull up his trousers and
I you know kind of bunch them up in a little wad, and I kind of continue
backwards towards the bathroom. And finally my back is up against the bathroom door. And we kind of
turn him around and he's standing over the toilet. And the door's wide open. And it seems, you
know, fine. And then
I'm not really sure what I need to do now I'm... 'Dad, you know, is there anything else I can
do for you?' And he says 'Yeah you can shut
the [bleeped] damn door and you know, get outta here.'
So I shut the door, and we arrive at Logan
Airport, horrible disgusting Logan Airport, and it's winter and it's disgusting and snowy and,
you know, ice piles,
and wretched, and we get out to the curb, and my brother's there in his
little Camry. And then we pile my father into the car and we just start
driving towards Cambridge which is where my brother lives. And,
you know, he's found some place for my father there, and we pull up at this place it's called the
?Cantobridgian? Convalescent
Center. We go in there and it is one of those places, it is a nursing home. And we check
my father in and it's kind of nighttime and we get him into his
room and tuck him into bed
and my brother and I are leaving the room and I feel really awful like God
we are just really horrible people. I mean, I can't even... this horrible
place. And we're leaving this poor guy here overnight and I just feel
really [bleeped] about myself. And I took him on this plane ride and it was just
awful and we get to the door and my father says 'Hey... you guys.'
We turn around and he says 'Don't forget to tip the girl on your way out
because they expect that in a hotel like this. [Laughter]